avec nous sur ce plateau benoît martin
secrétaire général de l'union
départementale cgt de paris bonjour et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
après avoir laissé son premier ministre
edward un philippe en première ligne
emmanuel macron tente désormais la
pédagogie sur la réforme il était en
déplacement à pau hier il a promis de
continuer à expliquer et concertée sur
cette réforme des retraites est ce qu'il
est parvenu à apaiser les tensions
manifestement pas vraiment non pas du
tout non mais écoutez il ya un espèce de
de continuité depuis deux ans et demi à
que le dossier sur la table
et donc voilà le edouard philippe l'a
bien dit à la télévision le dimanche
soir il veut aller jusqu'au bout alors
certes on monsieur macron peut-être
prend une tonalité un peu différente et
notamment et donne des signes également
sur les questions de répression
policière en disant qu'il ya des limites
mais sur cette question de la pédagogie
sur la réforme de la retraite les
français ne sont pas bêtes le monde du
travail a bien compris ce dont il s'agit
c'est pas de pédagogie dont on a besoin
c'est d'un recul ces deux on veut que ce
projet ne voie pas le jour tout
simplement pas un recul quand le premier
ministre alors philippe annonce le
retrait provisoire de la pivot mais
c'est provisoire c'est ça qui est
embêtant c'est provisoire et puis au
dans le même discours il dit nous irons
jusqu'au bout et donc en tout cas sur
cette histoire d'achever otages pivot ou
d'âge d'équilibré même si c'est différé
ou c'est renvoyé à la responsabilité des
organisations syndicales et patronales
sur des modalités de financement après
la conférence de financement etc tout ça
ça ça reste dans une même logique est en
tout cas le but c'est bien de basculer
sur un nouveau système de retraite par
répartition certes mais par point et
c'est ça le vraiment le noeud gordien et
d'affilée puisque vous l'évoquez qui
propose donc désormais que soit mise en
place une conférence sur l'équilibré le
financement du système de retraite
c'était une proposition de la cfdt une
conférence à laquelle les partenaires
sociaux sont invités à participer ce que
la cgt fera
partie des participants pas forcément
déjà le terme partenaire social nous
c'est pas marqué dans nos statuts nous
on est une organisation syndicale on
défend les les intérêts moraux et
matériels des salariés donc on est on
est partenaires un petit peu de force
ouvrière en semences de solidaires de la
fsu de la cgc de nombreuses forces en
mouvement contre ce projet participe et
ne pas participer en général on ne
pratique pas la chaise vide mais de
temps en temps on sait aller un endroit
claqué la porte en sortir voire ne pas y
aller alors ça dépend ça peut arriver
aussi
mais est ce que cette conférence de
financement n'est pas l'occasion aussi
de vous mettre d'accord et d'apporter
des solutions des propositions au
gouvernement
alors on ne refuse pas de parler des
questions de financement des retraites
mais on refuse d'en parler dans un cadre
qui serait contre nous le financement
des retraites
ça passe par plus de salaires plus
d'emplois et puis l'emploi des seniors
en particulier aujourd'hui on nous dit
on parle de l'âge à laquelle les gens
liquident leur retraite en faisant
croire que l'âge à laquelle on liquide
sa retraite serait lâche de départ réel
afin de faire d'activité il faut bien
voir que la moitié des gens qui
liquident leur retraite qui font valoir
leurs droits à la retraite ne sont plus
déjà en activité
ils sont un peu l'emploi ils sont dans
différents dispositifs etc
mais donc oui ce qu'on veut c'est le
plein emploi le plein salaire c'est ce
cas c'est cela qui fera des plaines
cotisations pour financer le système de
retraites
et pourquoi est ce que cette
inconscience de financement vous semble
la contrainte et bien parce qu'il ya
toujours
voilà ce taux 14% du pib n'est pas là il
n'est pas question d'aller au-delà donc
une question démographique y aura
davantage de retraités par par la
population active et voilà s'il reste à
14% du pib même si le pib augmente mais
voilà on ne sait pas exactement quelle
sera la croissance économique mais nous
on pense que ça choix de société de dire
qu'on peut aller au-delà des 14 % de
pays bas mais ce que refuse l
les discussions aient refusé ou pas
participer à cette conférence de
financement est ce que ce n'est pas le
risque aussi de vous voir au final
d'aller bien imposer une situation
puisque l'exécutif avec philippe l'a
expliqué si les partenaires sociaux ne
se mettent pas d'accord alors l'exécutif
prendra par ordonnance les mesures
nécessaires pour atteindre l'équilibré
en 2000 en 2027 et financer lé nouvelle
mesure de progrès social ce sont les
termes du gouvernement wii fit d'abord
nous contestons cette notion progrès
social d'une part et d'autre part on est
prêt toujours discuter ou à négocier
mais pas dans un dans un cadre qui ne
nous convient pas discuté dans le cadre
de l'accompagnement d'une réforme que
l'on combat parce qu'il ya toujours des
grèves
aujourd'hui il ya toujours des
manifestations demain il y aura des des
grandes manifestations et nouveau
partout en france il y a eu des blocages
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure dans
votre reportage en ce moment même il ya
des gens réunis à radio france pour
soutenir les les grévistes de radio
france mais des grévistes de de
différentes entreprises qui viennent et
les soutenir donc on voit bien si les
avocats qui jettent leurs robes noires
on voit aussi les infirmières qui lance
qui jettent leurs blouses blanches à
l'occasion parlant des voeux des
directeurs d'hôpitaux etc
ça ça foisonne d'activité de
contestation de partout et on irait
négocier l'accompagnement de quelque
chose que le doute ne veut pas c'est pas
possible
merci d'être venus réagir sur notre
plateau benoît martin secrétaire général
de l'union départementale cgt de paris